Steve Barclay the health secretary
writing and the independent suggesting
that strikes could go on for another
three months are you with the same
opinion well I certainly hope not but
that's really in the hands of the trade
unions we want to be as reasonable as
possible Steve Barkley and other
ministers have been meeting with Union
representatives to talk to them to see
if there are ways forward to discuss
next year's pay settlement and set out
our arguments on affordability there but
I think what you see with inflation
today means that if the international
factors are beginning tentatively to
work in the right direction the worst
thing that we could do domestically
would be to significantly increase
public sector pay and then entrench
inflation in the British economy and get
into a kind of wage spiral that will be
very detrimental to the economy so we
have to approach this with great caution
because inflation is the big evil that's
the thing that's diminishing people's
savings is increasing interest rates and
mortgage rates and making life generally
harder for everyone and so we have to
approach these public sector pay
discussion
with that broader mission in mind which
is to bring down inflation by at least
50 over the course of this year and to
that end you know you can take on uh the
rail unions you can take on uh the civil
servants unions but you know when it
comes to taking on the nurses you don't
have the support of the of the British
people and and I've seen the banners
that say a nurses for life not just for
covert well we have great respect for
nurses of course we do I'll give them
all um well it's not always as simple as
that in life argument okay because what
we have to judge is not only how can we
motivate and respect nurses and there is
a serious challenge with retention and
recruitment within the NHS we have to
balance that however with General
affordability to the taxpayer what can
the NHS with its record level of
investment right now afford secondly the
point about inflation which is so
critical to everybody in this country
and thirdly how can we manage this in a
sensible and appropriate great Manner
and the way that's done is through
independent pay review bodies and there
was an independent pay review last year
which concluded that nurses should get
the pay rise that they have we accepted
their recommendations this isn't an
independent is it it is independent okay
is it not uh presided over by the Prime
Minister and lots of government
ministers are involved in deciding how
much that money is well government
ministers play a role in it in that we
submit recommendations and give a
mandate to the independent pay review
body and we're doing that now for next
year the next financial year but then
it's ultimately for that group of
experts to look at the evidence to
listen to the perspective of the
workforce of trade unions
and come to a balanced judgment isn't it
don't ministers tell that pay review
body how much is in the past well we do
say what's affordable as you'd expect
because when any business or
organization considers how much it can
afford to pay its staff it has to work
out what is in the pot if you like like
but they also take into account what's
happening in the economy where inflation
is and is likely to be over the course
of the year and the particular
challenges in that sector to do with
Recruitment and Retention and at the
moment the independent period is gearing
up to work out what it should be a fair
second for the next financial year and
that's really our Focus right now and
they will be taking account of the
inflation on the first of February and
the fact that that's a coordinate
coordinated day of action it is
absolutely and one of my
responsibilities as immigration Ministry
is to keep our borders secure and allow
passengers to flow through our airports
as efficiently as possible and so I'm
working very hard to see that if that
strike includes border Force personnel
as it did over Christmas and New Year
that we have the right response and I
hope you and your listeners will agree
that the response we put in place over
Christmas and New Year was a good one we
use 600 Armed Forces Personnel 50
percent of border staff came into work
despite the strike action and actually
our borders were as secure as usual and
flowed if anything better than they do
on a normal working day and so that's
the kind of detailed work that I'm
involved in right now so that we can try
to ensure the country works as well as
it can on that day but the key thing is
that the unions don't proceed with those
strikes because all it's going to do
well they're going to well that's a
matter for them it is we can only
prepare but what I my message to them
would be think about the impact it's
going to have on working people across
the country and on the economy we know
that times are difficult right now what
we don't want to see is the economy
harmed by you know an act of self-harm
by further strike action that makes it
harder to get to work to cross the
border and of course to get access to
crucial Public Services it can be better
not let me talk about her to you if I
may um she has been writing in oh she's
um there's an article let's say in the
telegraph today about uh um transgender
conversion vision therapy she has said
she's not actually written to MPS as yet
I believe Tory MPS but she wants the ban
on trans conversion therapy not to
criminalize parents I'm not quite sure
where she's going with that do you
understand that yes I do
we all support the abolition of
conversion therapies which are you know
malicious attempts to convince people to
live lives outside of their gender and
so Banning people from doing those kind
of courses or interventions is
absolutely the right thing but this is a
much more complex issue than perhaps it
seems at first glance what we don't want
to see happen is parents loved ones
teachers people who want to provide
support and advice to Children put off
or criminalized from doing so if you're
a young person who is trans or is
thinking through the issues related to
trans it is absolutely right that you
should be able to turn to your parents
or trusted adults for support and advice
at that time and as a parent it is
absolutely right that I could provide
that kind of advice and support to my
chart without fear or without fear of
either being criminalized or there being
some other sanction as a result of doing
so so the way in which this new law will
need to be drafted is one which strikes
that balance so that the malicious
activities are criminalized and are
consigned to history but that
well-meaning loved ones and trusted
advisors to children can provide the
support and advice that they need to do
okay and so the way we're going to
handle this as a government is to do
detailed pre-legitive scrutiny which
those colleagues in Parliament who are
rightly concerned about how this will
work in practice can contribute to and
then we will craft careful legislation
in due course we're not going to rush
into this because I think it's a
surprisingly complex issue which we need
to treat appropriately okay we're almost
out of time but I wanted to ask you
about David Carrick that disgusting
disgraceful police officer who managed
to carry out a significant number of
rapes while he worked for the
Metropolitan Police my question is
twofold who is responsible for him being
allowed to stay in his post for 18 years
and should he have his pension removed
from him well on the on the second of
those two points
um the forfeiture of the pension is a
matter for the mayor of London but we
support his efforts to remove that
pension if that is indeed what he
chooses to do you know this is one of
the most egregious cases of police
misconduct in the history of the Met
perhaps in the history of British
policing and this disgusting individual
should not benefit from his years
serving in the metropolitan police there
now needs to be a very detailed
investigation as to exactly what
happened and who might have known about
this during his years of service Sir
Mark Rowley who's leading the
Metropolitan Police is focused on that
the Home Secretary has met with him to
get explicit assurances that he will be
working now intensively to understand
the events how this could possibly have
happened for such a prolonged period of
time and what we can do to make sure it
never happens again and then secondly
we've asked Dame Elish uh Angelini to do
a comprehensive review for us about the
culture in the Police Service about
vetting and recruitment procedures why
these cases of misogyny and Prejudice
seem to happen time and again and what
we can learn from that and we're asking
every police constabulary in the country
to improve their vetting and recruitment
procedures and giving them the funding
to do so there are other important
pieces of work on going like for example
from Dame Louise Casey who I've worked
very closely with in the past have the
utmost respect for and so I hope that
this body of work there was ongoing even
before we learned about this disgusting
case will enable change to happen
finally in the met and other police
force across the country we must leave
it there lots for us to unpick
throughout the course of the program
thank you very much indeed thank you for
the time much appreciated thank you